you know what a magnet is but did you
know that some magnets can be turned on
and off
one type of temporary magnet is called
an electromagnet
so what is electromagnetism
well the hint is in the name itself
electro for
electrical
and magnet for well magnet
let's take a moment to look at the
definition of what an electromagnet is
electromagnets are materials that become
magnets in the presence of electricity
but how does that even happen
well it turns out that electrically
charged particles in motion actually
have small magnetic fields around them
so if we run electricity through a wire
a magnetic field will be created around
the wire
now we can control the strength of this
magnetic field in a couple of ways
we can move more electric charges
through the wire at a faster rate
and we do this by increasing the
electrical current
the second way
is to increase the density
of the charged particles
and we can do this by looping the wire
into a coil
this gives us more charged particles
with magnetic fields in a small space
strengthening the magnetic force
the other thing we can control with
electromagnets is the direction of the
magnetic field
and we can do this by changing the
direction of the electricity
so if we go back to this wire example
from earlier and change the direction of
the electricity running through that
wire
well the magnetic fields will also
change direction
this makes electromagnets quite
different from permanent magnets so
let's take a look at that and compare
permanent magnets
to electro magnets
electromagnets are typically made of
loops of wire in a coil
the wire is typically made of metal like
copper
and wrapped around pieces of metal like
iron nickel or cobalt
this is different from a permanent
magnet because permanent magnets don't
need this wire
permanent magnets also have fixed poles
you can't change the north and south
poles on these magnets
but as we now know
for electromagnets we can change these
poles by changing the direction of the
electrical current
so if we have an electromagnet with a
north and south pole that looks like
this and a current flowing in this
direction
well we can change the poles and the
direction of the current
permanent magnets have a fixed strength
but we just talked about how we can
change the strength of electromagnets so
electromagnets have adjustable strength
and finally electromagnets need a power
source in order to generate the
electricity required to produce magnetic
fields
permanent magnets do not need a power
source
but this means that we can also turn
electromagnets on and off which is
pretty cool when you think about it
on the other hand permanent magnets are
always on
now you might be thinking if electrical
charge can affect magnetism
can magnetism
affect electrical charge
absolutely let's look at how we can do
that
the only way to do this is by changing
the magnetic field around the charge
particles this can be done by moving
magnets closer or further away from the
particles
or by spinning the magnets
in fact spinning magnets is how most of
the electricity we use in cities and
homes is generated
a turbine spins a magnet inside a coil
to produce electricity and since
electromagnets need a power source this
turbine is powered by wind
so you can see why electromagnetism is
an incredibly important force and this
isn't the only important application of
it
we use electromagnets in all sorts of
other applications from motors to
speakers and even medical scanners